let's bring in wisconsin senator ron
johnson member of the senate homeland
security committee
senator good morning to you good morning
guys
hey what'd you make of kamala harris's
trip to
her photo op last week in el paso she
was criticized by republicans for not
being at the
right spot you say you were actually
where she should have gone
well yeah they took her to a point in
the border where she wouldn't see the
crisis
and so the press wouldn't report on the
crisis and of course that's what's been
going on and
and brian you're exactly right i offered
an amendment to force administration to
actually build the
250 miles of wall that has been bought
and paid for about 2 billion
every democrat except joe manchin voted
against that amendment so
again what they've gotten good at
they've gotten very efficient at
processing and dispersing illegal
illegal immigrants across this country
they're taking credit for that but
they're just fueling the crisis they're
exacerbating the problem
and tens of thousands of uh those that
were thrown out during the trump years
were
visited were uh were act evaluated to
not be worthy of admission here
uh they're being called back by the bite
administration we urge you to reapply to
come here
what under what school of thought is
that a good idea
it's not a good idea uh you you just
simply can't understand what this
administration is doing we literally are
apprehending now about 6 000 people
per day that's i mean that's a large
caravan
every day being processed uh some of
them have been returned
others are being dispersed uh but this
crisis is is not going away
it's just under everybody's radar
because the press isn't covering it
you held an event uh talking about the
vaccine and you came under some fire for
it
because there's some people that have
taken the vaccine and they've had
adverse reactions to it
we have a mother a sound bite from from
that that event
a mother she's a 12 year old daughter
she volunteered
to take the pfizer vaccine during the
clinical trials
and the child now is in a wheelchair
listen to this mother
for the past five months maddie has been
here
and has nine times three times for a
total of two months in the hospital
what i want to ask employment volunteer
for the buyers of travel
why why don't
just in case the audience couldn't
understand what she was saying she said
that her daughter's been to the er nine
times been hospitalized three times for
a total of two months you can see her
emotion
your reaction well first of all
everybody that we had that event
is pro-vaccine uh three of them actually
participate in the trials the
drug companies have largely abandoned
them but just that was stephanie
her daughter's maddie i think how she
feels as she's given assurance this is
incredibly safe but his daughter has
suffered severe neurological
problems like the other four women as
well they've been
suffering these problems for months the
cdc
the nih is pretty well ignoring them the
drug companies ignoring them
all they wanted was to be seen to be
heard and to be believed
so they can get treatment so they can be
cured and hopefully
raise the issue so others won't be
similarly harmed
yeah uh joe biden's going to go to
wisconsin today to talk about
infrastructure you and the other
republicans are for real
infrastructure but the democrats are for
the kind of infrastructure that is
social infrastructure
aoc i think yesterday said yeah we need
bridges but we also need babysitters
well what democrats want to do is they
want to create more long-term
entitlements that can never be turned
down
can never be reduced that will
completely mortgage our children's
future
uh replyments are absolutely for
building infrastructure that here's a
deal that they have on the table right
now
repurpose the 700 billion dollars from
the last 1.9 trillion dollar
air quote covert relief package that
isn't being spent till 2022 through 2028
700 billion dollars that would be more
than enough uh they could have that
passed uh literally
within a couple days uh they just reject
it right uh senator johnson thanks so
much appreciate it
have a great day